greetings from podcast Ville it's Monday
July the 1st you filthy [ __ ]
the church is the church is brought to
you by zip recruiter listen I have to
tell you a business owner it's tough to
find the right employees it's tough too
many applications too many people
calling you you lose 22 hours of work
and manpower trying to hire somebody but
listen those days are over would you
know why cuz Uncle Joe is introducing
you to zip recruiter zip recruiter it
sends your job to over a hundred of the
web's leading job boards but they don't
stop there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and invites them to apply for
your job listen like I said hiring is a
challenging but there's one place you
could go to make hiring simple fast and
smart
that's super Cruiser com what I'm doing
is this right now the church family can
get zip recruiter for free we're
starting off the month with something
free here
ok free exclusive at zip recruited calm
slash shirts eh you are CH that's zip
recruiter dot-com slash Church CH you
are CH zip recruiter com the smartest
way to hire the church is also brought
to you by manscape com
listen to me it's July you don't have to
September you can't dress in white after
July 1st you can't have hairy nuts and
your [ __ ] can't look like a [ __ ] bat
cave you understand me you got to keep
that [ __ ] hair down you gotta trim me
I look nice even in that sack listen I
have little designs on my nutsack and
make one landscape that's how I roll
uncle Joey's here to tell you enough to
cut your dick off to keep yourself nice
sharp and clean the suffering ends now
with manscape you get it done without
the [ __ ] pain and anxiety
they got precision tools for the family
jewels and the [ __ ] love stick
you understand me
so what we're doing today is this the
church family gets twenty not ten twenty
percent off your first order when you
use code church at manscape calm
when you use code church at manscape
comma if you order the perfect package
which is tremendous it includes a crop
reserve especially formulated the
Ottoman so you boys won't stink like a
skunk and it also has the Reviver a
sprint a spritz that tones and refreshes
your nutsack and your [ __ ] love stick
and it keeps you nice and cool these
humid [ __ ] days comes ahead you
understand me like I said that's
manscape calm use promo code church for
20% off your first order delivered the
house and remember keep your [ __ ]
nuts clean Lee kick this [ __ ]
meal this is the first song Harvey's
going to play at the court hearing put
this on and it's just gonna crack on the
church delays my little brother
D'Agostino zoria what's happening
brother thank you for having me whatsapp
thank you I've just been thinking about
you lately and I've been watching you
and you got your first headline week
this week and I wanted to celebrate it
we thank you very proudly I've known you
for ten years now yeah you would just
get hair on your dick when I make it
look at you you're headlining you're a
big shot now look at you all going out
and doing the town and [ __ ] but it's
weird because you made me think a lot
about comedy when you told me that you
had gotten your first headline spot I
was like I assume I'm gonna get my first
feature spot it was Labor Day 1995 I was
doing comedy for years was I ready
[ __ ] no you know I had the featured
bars show that's an endline bar shows
but you're not official - you're in a
club like need to top all this [ __ ] you
won I got 92 minutes that's great I know
that's the punchline is you ain't [ __ ]
and I am like yeah a little clubs oh hi
you the headline you really another have
wannabe you're learning I totally know
but I still remember getting my first
night to feature I think I was more
excited to feature than the headline
like the featured look to me was
everything like it was featuring his fun
man it's the best job in the [ __ ]
plan there's no pressure no pressure
yeah right like when you're on stage I'm
just sitting there eating dinner
watching you I don't have to worry about
I did my 20 and I had
blast you've practice and that's all
you're doing this long as you know who
you are before you go up on that stage
on what your purpose is to that show
as a feature act he'll make your life a
lot easier you know there's a lot of
comics that go up well boy that wouldn't
lay enough usually I make an [ __ ] of
he said there's no more dirty air and
filthier but to get that first features
probably I I stopped my life like I was
supposed to go back to Colorado and be a
dad and be a [ __ ] worked the sports
betting service they had already moved
me up in tomorrow an office with three
guys and when John Fox who was booking
the comedy underground that's the first
Club ever to really feature me I'm lying
to you
the first club to really feature and he
was Joey's and Dearborn Michigan in
Detroit but it wasn't living it was like
a co MC type deal like I was really an
MC glorifying like I got 20 minutes it
was a club that only the two man shows
yeah so I had already done time and then
he did feature me that summer he
featured me the summer of 94 but it was
just possessed it was just a train wreck
like I why they didn't boo me I was like
on a bombing Street like I was just out
of Amish how many nights the weekend the
first time I featured at Joey's was
Labor Day Oh 95 and I met Carol in
Michigan that's how I met dick the
stripper girl that I'm in love with and
stuff and I was a feature that weekend
and it was just a disaster I could be as
long as I can with you I'm really good
woman going I don't know if they're even
though let me like I was waiting for a
call my hotel room like it was that type
of situation like I'm waiting for the
call for them to fire me yeah well love
it let me go up on Friday to shows I was
like all right we're halfway there and
then they let me go up on Saturday and
then Sunday they paid me I was like are
you [ __ ] him yeah I [ __ ] sucked
you know was $250 yeah you know the
feature then it's the same money now
but in Seattle like that would the
reason why I made Seattle I was so happy
about Seattle because it was considered
an a club it was really considered one
of the top clubs in the country because
of the contest so when in a club is when
you're really really really a featured
I'm legitimized like now it's over now
they can't stop me type deal yeah and
when I did the Seattle Club I was a
little better
I had improved a lot that summer just by
living in Seattle and doubling my spots
being more comfortable on stage so but
ice I got 250 bucks I'll never forget
and they mailed your check took a month
so yeah took a month I want to get a
change on Fox
a month for 215 hours and he give you an
advance of $50 only on Thursday so you
got a check for $250 a spot to feature
that it was [ __ ] brutal why do you
think it went bad you just weren't funny
like you're saying it went awful this
wasn't right listen I don't think I was
ready uh-huh
but then I got I don't think anybody
else is really do you know saying when
you get thrown up to the first time you
probably get thrown up dick to somebody
that you show up it's never your own
merit you're in a good position like you
were there yeah you were there at the
wrong at the right place right time yeah
you want me to what time you got uh uh
uh and then your mind you he goes like
20 I got a strong 20 okay you got
[ __ ] eight and you still got 12 more
to go but that's as much as I don't like
seeing that happen the comics that's
what needs to happen yeah I'm the time
to bring you you need reality checks you
need reality checks to give you if not
you just go up then you do great every
night it's think it's that easy to be
again me talk I've been doing comedy 28
years I still get reality check sir yes
well I get off the stage and go I gotta
have a long talk of myself so I'm gonna
continue doing this [ __ ] that is not
acceptable
so I I'm kind of an I'm interests
because I know there's a lot of young
comics who listen to this and I'm I had
a situation to happen this week and I
don't know if I made the right decision
and I've been asking people
I gotta have to do a bar show and they
said do you want a headlining 2:30 2:45
and I'm nowhere near being a headliner
and I think to be honest if I did every
joke I ever rode I might have 25 mic if
I did every joke I ever wrote so my
initial reaction was I said listen I
don't mind going a blast but I don't
have 30 to 45 I have about 20 to 25 tops
and she said fine I'm still doing it but
I wasn't sure should I have should I
have just said yes I'll do it and try to
do it or is it better to say to be
honest with people when they ask you to
be honest yeah honesty is always worked
for me
listen if you're opening up for louis
c.k i don't give a [ __ ] if you let
yourself off they're not there to see it
right yeah you know when those feature
spots you have to pay Louis so much that
you gotta save on the feature use a bump
feature pay him 50 bucks to have the
guys just happy to be there now he's got
a credit I opened up a Lewis II can
total in here and they don't care you
know let him to go do 15 [ __ ] minutes
and [ __ ] like that me for me I'd rather
be honest you apply for a job then you
[ __ ] me that's got insurance and
dental and benefits and the guy asks you
do you know how to do this if you say
I've done it before you got a tricky
situation there I mean listen don't get
me wrong there's some [ __ ] that you can
learn in two minutes you don't need to
be a [ __ ] genius
you don't really some should dig in the
trench you know it's just some [ __ ] that
you don't need to be a genius and you
could pick up this some job is that you
can try on what comedy for me I took a
lap to that yesterday when I got back
from Columbus I took a nap when I got up
for some reason I just started thinking
about my past talking about being a
thief and being a creepy guy and all
that [ __ ] and I thought about stand-up I
could look both you guys in the eye like
I was a thief for all my [ __ ] life
all my life I couldn't be trusted you
couldn't leave a dime out in front of me
you know that type of [ __ ] I never stole
and you know like when I got into comedy
I got into comedy to renew my life you
know people say aren't his life it
really is art is life you know I met you
10 years ago what were you doing you're
working
yeah you were young kids you know I went
down there you took care of me he really
took care of me I never forgot them well
I wasn't doing spots at the store then
that's right I remember that you weren't
gone there
I was only coming to you on Thursdays
Fridays and Saturdays I call you 10:30
yeah and you ask how and whatever the
[ __ ] name is sometimes Monday's even
well then reset the contest to have you
come close that's right Monday nights I
would go down there and [ __ ] do time
10-15 minutes before Gabriel's thing
yeah that's where I got the material for
gay boys it's gonna stand up revolution
hog work that with you and you took care
of me and you you know you got the C
commie from a different angle from the
bottom floor yeah that's why you're on
the show tonight because of what you've
done in the last nine [ __ ] years you
know you got divorced
you got that albatross off your [ __ ]
back and when you got married yeah I was
a little concerned I was like are you
trying to do calmly why are you putting
this weight back in your life but she's
turned out to be a great partner right
she's very understanding you know a lot
of women and the beginning comedy is
great
he's so funny oh my god but I don't see
Janet [ __ ] bars you hear nothing so
you eliminated that yeah Jen was that
shows with you like the comedy still huh
I'd have to pull you aside and say
something to you yeah handle your
business by yourself and she gets it too
like you know I just gotta go down there
and do my thing you know she told her
you know it's so weird I love when
people come to the comedy store to see
me but I have friends that call me and
go can I write down with you I really
don't like that
I'm till appoint lately I don't mind but
I have because I could talk to Lee in
the car yeah you know Lee this have to
bother me leo just look out the [ __ ]
window
yeah I used to go with you all the time
yeah I like you guys I don't have to get
a spy you just go to the paid regular
weathers on stage this is great with you
smell is about out smelling all right
you'll smell this is only through your
face even if you had a congested [ __ ]
can't wait Karma's gonna get you comers
gonna get like a my 600-pound laughs got
one down plane and you'll be stranded on
the tarmac
that's [ __ ] you contract no you [ __ ]
you I smell you look Jew farts one time
yeah I did one party back I was humus
and God knows what was in that lizard me
I can never fire all day and I get here
I have no farts you gotta save your
farts and condense them like I do put
them in the [ __ ] back clip anyway
yeah so why don't you like people go
down there with you because you're
focusing yeah you're focusing yeah
you're driving you're thinking of
material to say I'm gonna put the rock
and radio on on the way down I listen to
the radio it's all in my head just
thinking about [ __ ] I I have an idea you
know before I leave I write some down
it's not really it's just a little road
map to have in my head the percentages
of you doing better looking over your
material before you go onstage you get I
have a son and you're doing better if
you look over your material everybody
knows that's funny I said something this
Wednesday on the podcast that really
made a lot of sense and I got a lot of
emails of it a lot of calls about it it
was a very funny line but I thought
about what he said he said that there's
actually comics there's comedians that
actually think about what they're gonna
say before I go they go onstage you know
that's a confusing line for a lot of
young comics like what the [ __ ] you talk
about Kirby always says to look over
your material a heavy asset list you
know Messiah and I thought about what he
said I talked to Rogen about it me a
Rogen were laughing about that line he's
some kind of God that was such because
Mike one by one podcast put on huh
whatever there was just him talking
about it you know they look at their
[ __ ] iPhones you know they you just
have to think of you know you shouldn't
think about it it's really true
and it works me this week I'm in
Columbus don't think about it it should
be organic mm-hmm I have a route I
always make it as organic as I can when
I go on stage because I have a rod I'm
gonna take I just [ __ ] it up on purpose
[ __ ] it up on purpose to make my dick
get hard to make me excited because if I
run the set the same way every night
I'm gonna die yeah I'm gonna die I'm not
type of comic so I have a route but I'm
thinking about what he said just be
funny
don't talk about jokes just go up them
be funny
and you know what I wrote like five
jokes are sweet because I kept the light
in my mind you weren't so kept to your
script yeah that's always been the case
whenever I stick to my script I eat a
bag of dicks that's so interesting
either bag of dicks whenever I step to
my script I eat a bag of dicks is not
organic it's not organic yeah I have a
route looks at I'm gonna go to the
Comedy Store tonight I'm gonna take the
[ __ ] Laurel Canyon and hook a right
on Sunday and go to the county store
right but I go up the [ __ ] to Laurel
Canyon and there's two Priuses the crash
there's an electrical fire and I can't
get through what do you do you hire a
helicopter no you make a u-turn and you
go down two blocks past the school
what should what's a high school the
expensive one on Laurel Canyon would
cost money to go denzel's kids oh yeah I
don't know the name such as I see you
right or wrong yeah take it all to the
exit uh-huh so the same thing happens
for your material you know if you go up
then those first three [ __ ] jokes
that you brilliantly wrote don't work
talk about your dad get away from that
material and slide back into it I just
said this is on about you the other day
is a you're never as dangerous as when
you're not working on something and what
I mean by that is like when you were
working on something you have something
coming up like you're very scripted you
personally I've noticed that when you
don't have anything coming up no that's
the longer the most dangerous I don't
want it that's why do I want to shoot a
special again like with Netflix yeah
don't have all the shoes but you've got
it you you're just like I don't have
anything to prepare for you can just do
whatever the [ __ ] you want like that's
when you're at your best
yeah no that's I don't want to do ass
but I don't want to be put in that box
again that's how it's a priest I was
like [ __ ] huge huge I'm Owen - with
specials because I had to become fine -
something in my mind I can find it
myself to be honestly nobody can find it
me now I can blame whoever the [ __ ] I
want nobody can find to be me I tried to
become a stand-up comic
and I forgot about who the [ __ ] I was
now they realize it till when I got on
the plane back from Vegas after the
Netflix special I never used that
material again I wasn't even a material
yeah that was weird
you didn't even do both shows you didn't
do your material do you know yeah like
I've never really done that material
again like it's just done like I I was
so sick of feeling like that I was so
sick of feeling like a stand-up comic
about to go onstage you know I had a
friend years ago that went on let him
and I saw what they would put him
through not let him in the Tonight Show
what The Tonight Show put him through
and I decided like my fourth year at
comedy I don't want to be a little it's
a night you like I knew it
I don't even a couple months ago they
were looking for edgier comics for the
Tonight Show
they put Robert Kelley on how a bunch of
people were making tapes I didn't make a
tape I don't ever want to be in that
position but your approach to one guy
asked me you should make a tape they're
looking for edge your comics on Leno uh
whatever that is that on the show I just
didn't want yeah just don't ever want to
work on those restraints no more I'm too
old I'm too old them to set in my ways I
want to work the way I worked in the
original if I don't work like that
across the country people shouldn't pay
the comes in that's the way they want to
see me work I work at the store no
predetermined nothing just go out there
and be a [ __ ] Savage put mice in my
mind I'm on the corner with six of my
buddy and we already smoked dope who
were about to go either [ __ ] deli
sandwich this is the [ __ ] we would do if
I put myself there that's what I'm
dangerous
that's what I'm dangerous once that leg
goes back I'm the [ __ ] quarterback
from New England it's his round like it
goes back you're done yeah don't let
that right leg go back for more than
three seconds that's a touchdown
yeah it won't them what time you give
Brady you're done once he steps back
absolutely you're done it when you play
Tom Brady don't let him step back you
want to beat the normal on pages don't
let him step back beat him to that
second leg and you'll beat the Patriots
all the time nobody's figured that out
tough to do yeah it's tough to do but
that's the same thing with me
realize that once that leg goes back I
got you
I feel comfortable and for a while I did
edibles and I did xanax to try to relax
on stage
none of that [ __ ] works I don't want to
be relaxed on stage I want to be up
there like an animal when I get those
anxiety panic attacks man I just breathe
through yeah [ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it I'm
just talking about this with the guests
on my podcast recently is we're talking
about like not being under any influence
when you're on stage and a lot of people
do it for the nerves before they go on
stage but I to me there's never been
I've never been in the habit
I mean you've known me a long time I
don't do anything before I want to stage
it there's nothing better than the
feeling of just being on stage and
nothing else
substituting it you know if I want to
feel that moment I like smoking pot and
going onstage I didn't like drinking
going on stage between you and I don't
like in comics drink on sticks yeah I
just don't like when they have one up
there with them there's certain comics
for the boozes yeah I don't mind they
get away with you know I'm saying Bert
is the real deal wrong light Ron White
is the real yeah you makes it look good
there's guys that go up there to drink
to be cool yeah I see right through that
yeah he'd actually have a drink I have
the audience sees right through that
yeah you're following me yeah so I I see
right through it doe see right through
it you know a lot of young comics bring
a drink up mm-hmm lot of young comics
even that open mics yeah don't bring a
drink up why fade you with them bring a
water you doing 40 minutes 20 minutes
you gonna get thirsty
yeah but to bring a drink up is [ __ ] I
don't like those I like when they bring
a water when they're doing five and a
towel yeah amazed have you been doing
comedy now 10 but we had conversation
once that this was all you loved as a
child yeah like you would know every
[ __ ] comedy out you watch all the
specials I still do notes the whole
[ __ ] I just watched Gaffigan his new
one today how was it very good a little
different than what he normally does but
still Gaffigan they're on got flex it's
on prime you got prime Amazon Prime yeah
it's free on prime that's right Amazon
is shooting specials now yeah it's
really good
you've always been a big student of the
game like you've always I know this not
about you've always been a big student
like you
I enjoy it if you play football you'd
watch a lot of film watch a lot of game
film yeah and one of those guys and now
to see that you had lightning I mean it
I'm happy for you thank you and really
happy for you when I thought about
booking this week ago that's right yeah
I saw it on Twitter the other day that
you're gonna be on and whatever and I
know you know what I want to celebrate
them bring them up because I know what
do you think he is journey so far this
time he is I think it's just the
beginning I think that you know you get
into little moments of like man this is
so hard and I just I think I haven't
seen anything yet I think that it's just
the beginning of and I'm now I'm
starting a new chapter and I'm gonna go
through the challenges of that and I'm
gonna start hitting things of uh you
know that's that's one of the cool
things about being a feature as we said
there's no pressure and now you're gonna
start feeling the pressure of ticket
sales before I could just show up and if
it didn't sell out and by god that's on
the headline for right now don't worry
about tickets it yeah for right now for
your next two years just a three years
you're gonna still feature a lot and
then this year the headline twice mm-hmm
unless you headlines five times next
[ __ ] you're going to a club with me on
Friday and Saturday but your headline
Thursday right you know I'm saying and
you'll get 22 people who kids yeah just
learn how to headline that's something
that I didn't know how to do I didn't
learn how to headline tonight so I was a
headline of five years in or something
like that that's when I actually put
time into learning how to headline
anybody could do 40 minutes that's the
will will liked it oh you need to just
go up then do 40 minute no it's not 40
minutes it's it's got to be crafted you
have to know when to pull back when to
attack they drop tab when they chat to
chat that's a complete different world
there's so many variables that you have
to learn how to work around and then
after you suck 200 bags of dicks as a
headline you know then you remember I
saw that one in 2005 like once I got the
longest shard that bumped me up on him
ha so a bunch of a rooms headlined me so
I was done with featuring the only
person I would feature for was rogue
that was it
you don't want me as that line I'm not
working you up that's the next decision
you make your three years in that
decision when you go you know what am i
feature no how'd you feel in 2005 when
they bumped up that but because of the
movies you feel you were ready for or
did you feel that the movie kind of gave
you that bump I was cheated I cheated
the National the public I've moved up
because of the movie right I moved up
because of the movie and the bigger the
size of the role I just bought myself up
bill burr hooked me up with his booking
agent and he started booking me as
airline Wow and I saw I have no shame in
saying this I saw thousands of people
walk out over those years you know
thousands thousands yeah I walked
thousands people they're gonna go see
the guy from The Longest Yard yeah I
don't know you're acting like all my
actors life especially then when I was
doing coke and I was really unorthodox
and 30 percent of moment you know 25
minutes of my material was cocaine so at
first it was funny but after you watch
it on tape like somebody taped me in
Atlanta one time I almost drew the
[ __ ] tape out it's not a crime you
know I assist a drug and taking all my
mind my drug my induced of comedy was
cocaine-induced mmm every joke had
something that would cocaine and stuff
like that I didn't know what I was doing
I walked the houses people because of
they were offended or because you they
were didn't like your material they did
everyone funny from 2005 2004 then I got
to the point where I was going in on
Thursday or Wednesday for row giving me
an Ari will call headline and we get 22
peoples and there'd be one guy that go
crazy over us we love you more than Joe
Rogan that type of [ __ ] yeah I'm not
gonna see him a month coming this and
you guys you know there was that type of
[ __ ] but I say from 2006 from 2004 to
2011 I was just doing 45 minutes that's
it I was just doing 45 minutes people
were walking out because the material
was obnoxious the material wasn't good
I was very r-rated
I was just making fat you know I was
sweaty there'd be puddles under my chest
it was just a gross huh same it was just
well I snorted coke
I would sweat a lot like I would sweat
just coming up here you would see me
right now I'd be sweating my body I did
so much blow was selling it I had a
temperature that was always sweat and
you know you know you didn't do blow
before you performed so was okay the
night before always from the night
before or just whatever wasn't gonna
come on yeah I don't sweat like that
anymore on stage I did you know whatever
I did in New Orleans was hot and humid
places I sweat but not like that but
from 2004 to 2010 or 11 it was just a
horror show and I got cleaned up from
coke in 2007 and I started carrying a
little more you know and then when I
thought about because there was about
two years I told about quit from 2009 to
2011 I was ready to hang up the gloves
not cuz I was angry and nothing I didn't
think it was for me I just didn't think
it was for me I didn't think I had the
aptitude to become a headliner I didn't
want to put the time in anymore
I'd already done my time I felt that
I've gotten what I was gonna get from
this town do you know my answer was like
I'm done I just worked I wait to Greg
Garcia called me one of my other buddies
it puts me in a TV show I'll keep my
insurance up Wow and I'll get a day job
that's what I was thinking about doing
you were gonna stay in California though
yeah I wasn't staying the valley and
then when I moved up and I wasn't going
through a store no more I said I have to
do something with my life so I made a
promise to myself that I would dry I
didn't tell this to anybody I would
drive to the Irvine improv
I'm Thursday night so whenever a comic
got in and I would park in the back and
I would go through the front I would
talk to a couple of door guys or
whatever they know who I was and if they
were sold out I would sit the comics
table yeah go and watch the headline
when saving that light I would just run
out before the show and get my car and
leave just watching the show watched I
just wanted to watch headline as an
alert
I watched Ralphie for two nights and
that was a minute I mean I stayed around
for him he was my friend I didn't do
guest spots I didn't ask him for guest
spots I just wanted to see headliners
the guy that opened my eyes the most at
that time was greg Giraldo I'm watching
Greg that weekend I think I want on
Thursday Wednesday I want to get on
Sunday and watching Greg really really
let me know that I was [ __ ] up as a
headline and I you know went to see BER
I want to see everybody I want to see
everybody I could you know a couple
women I forget her well with the see
Liza
okay I went down and so on Liza do 45 or
50 I didn't say don't anybody I wasn't
allowed you know I wasn't going to the
store I really wasn't doing a lot of
comedy I would only open a frog and I
would book a couple weekends on my own
to make a few bucks during the weekend
book a couple one-nighters but I wasn't
killing myself I wasn't taking planes
when I'm Travis but I basically went
down hill watch time and I was doing
comedy [ __ ] 17 years at that point 15
years or something Wow
so looking back like when you guys talk
about like you you jump the line a
little bit with the movie do you wish
you had said no let me feature a little
bit more no no no you know when I went
to Auburn Oh crane for jujitsu I wasn't
even close to being a blue buff I'm
still not I'm still a horrible blue buff
sometimes when you push somebody they
see the they see it a little faster you
know sometimes they see the rainbow a
little faster it was time for me to
start headline like it was time for me
to start outlining I was in a state of
limbo that's why I was thinking about
quitting because a lot of people didn't
want me in front of them
do you know as I am like there was a
hack could call it improv and go can you
book me as a feature cuz the headliner
headline whoever was that say I don't
want to follow him all weekend so I was
at that point so the only person who
would follow me would be Rogan you know
yeah I catch a couple of off weeks and
I'd get into an hour with the headline
you know midweek he doesn't like it I
improvise he doesn't like like curse
yeah improvise you can't do that there
was a comic I work I've heard that
before too that told me not to improvise
why I heard guys like I've had guys time
I don't do cry work before me
I ever crowd work with improvise same
shape same [ __ ] okay same [ __ ] I thought
I thought I'd just go off what everyone
done you know and it was it was rough
sometimes it's because they do crowd
work as their go-to when maybe don't
want to do material but main thing is
could you wrap you rattle up the
audience oh yeah totally
that's what now they say like a week
goes up and I'll leave people who talked
to Lee mm-hmm they broke the fourth wall
though to Spain rested that's what
happened that's why a lot of headlines
don't like it unless you're really
really good at it then they don't like
because you're really really but no it's
a 50/50 shot when you improvise they
just didn't like it so I was like I had
to you know Comedy Central didn't like
me so that wasn't gonna push me up I
just needed a push I needed that push
that nobody could give you it's just a
push of comedy he's just waiting around
there's a bunch of feature acts now
they're just waiting for a home run to
happen then they move up they're already
like [ __ ] blowing out be headline
it's like they go up on stage with a
like a headline I like it what I'm
telling like when I was like 2007-2008 I
would work clubs where those features
are deadly they run off - that's also
those be room features are deadly
they're on Orthodox they don't have a
car they got a DUI they got in jail for
beating up their girlfriend those guys
are deadly those guys a few golfer
cocaine and rage you know they're mad
cuz the guys they started with didn't
they all made and they didn't yeah you
know guys like that so you really have
to have your game up on top but what's
the what was the lesson you took from
how long did you work at the haha for I
think like five years what
was the lesson you learned out of the
haha working to have a comedy club in
the beginning and you worked it before
you got on stage you got on stage before
you worked I got on stage before I
worked there okay so I was a comic first
I definitely I learned many things I
learned a lot what not to do
also you learn things like you see
comics do stuff and I see what pissed
the owners off that the comics did so I
know how to be respectful when I go to a
club I think when you work at a comedy
club
you you have an upper hand when you
start to go to comedy clubs because I
hear the door guys at the store old-time
complain that some comic walks past them
and just goes like yo I'm a comic you
know and that's rude and and and those
are the guys are gonna put you up on
Mondays you know so I learned that when
you cuz I worked the door you were you
walk up and you go hey I'm Lee nice to
meet you I'm a comic what's your name
cool man nice to meet you can I hang out
for a little bit like you know I mean I
learned little things like that and then
obviously watching the comics did you
ask a lot of headliner questions Joe
because when I worked at a comedy club
I asked questions mm-hmm see I worked in
a comedy club neither have the balls to
get up on stage yeah
that was the final test to see if I
wanted to do comedy I'm very you know
anal also so I went to a comedy club and
got a job like nine months I started as
a door guy then I became a sound guy and
then I was the door guy combination
sound guy combination barback yeah and
they were running me ragged but to me it
was an education because I got to ask
questions that's all I did
I just asked to headline that if I get
one question out of the headliner that
made my job you know the to end week
they paid me or whatever they paid me
worth its while I would ask Road
questions about booking are you ever
scared you know the biggest fear is what
you're about to go through right now in
the next three years like I said this
year you'll headline twice and then
she'd online four times but then the
following year if you do your work
correctly you'll headline ten times now
there comes a time that you have to quit
your job
mm-hmm like you have to and that's one
of the hardest things for a comic that's
one of the scariest
things for anybody is going into the
unknown not knowing yeah it's me saying
to you listen I need John Wednesday in
your wanker I got a job well you can't
online it yeah you're gonna get three of
those and then you'd have to make a
decision you gonna get three of those
people I need your Wednesday morning for
press and you're gonna go I got a day
job I can't be that don't find it and
then you ask yourself why did God put me
on this planet and [ __ ] work in a
[ __ ] office do [ __ ] commie I want
to do [ __ ] town me so now you're
gonna decide what the [ __ ] you want to
do that is the hardest decision for a
human being never mind a comedian who's
on that cusp cuz you have to make that
cusp once you're making about a thousand
a month of comedy there's only one way
to double that thousand to two thousand
that's my quick new danger yeah that
that's a that's a very scary thing for a
person so that was very scary for me
like I already had a wife I already had
a child and I'm like I want to do comedy
what and they're like in the beginning
you're not gonna make normal and when I
took the course well I took the stand up
comedy course for three weeks the first
week he spoke about money and I wasn't
important but he also gave us a chart of
what they were paying you in comedy
clubs in 1980 and what they were paying
you and comedy clubs in nineteen and
people left the class MC got 1,500 a
week
wow what a feature act got that's pretty
good 2500 a week in a plane ticking like
a headline I got like 350 najin ahead
lot 2500 a headline I got like 1,000 a
week I've heard that before yeah
I've asked these questions there were
people like the comic strip
you know Paso he wanted to be an
aspiring comic he couldn't make it as a
comic he didn't want to put the work in
I mean he's a great guy but I'm gonna
say nothing bad about him but Bart told
me these stories and he would just come
up to the comedy store to notebook with
our notebook with a calendar and as you
got offstage you goalie come in he's a
plane ticket what are you doing October
12th to the 16th not here no passing
with me Wow
yeah gasps Tina what are you doing you
know he would just give you a plane
ticket in those days ever see he's got
plane tickets so the boom was
85 or something but it crashed when I
got into it people saying don't get into
common it's really bad yeah
don't get into it it's downtown I don't
get it I just wanted to be happy I
didn't get into it because of downs or
the stock market the Dow was up I got
into it because I needed something to
fill the voids in my life I just needed
something yeah don't get into comedy
right now but yeah that time you were
gonna get paid anyway it wasn't gonna be
him nowhere near so but I remember Jeff
harms the guy took the teacher I'm very
grateful to today but teaching that
class for $33 Wow
33 dollars and then the last week guys
dual three minutes in front of him and
we'll hang on a stage she said don't
leave until I talk to uni to listen man
you could do something like this he goes
why don't you get a job cuz I was like I
don't know if I didn't do this [ __ ] I
got a wife and a kid
he's a sore I saw that Roseanne cuz
Roseanne it broke the air that time I
started at Roseanne was breaking out of
Denver so devil was the hotbed all these
comics and movements are Denman out
there thinking that that was the hot man
I lived there so I was just doing comedy
there but when I got into comedy
Roseanne was on fire so everybody was
trying to whatever the [ __ ] that was 91
91 July of 91 where did you take the
class in Boulder the University of
Colorado in Boulder I found it by
mistake huh by mistake I just wanted to
be a comic I didn't know where to start
and I looked through the paper and there
it was I was like [ __ ] so I took that
class in like 90 and I didn't get on
stage till 91 damn I think I think that
class April of 90 yeah April 9th it took
me a year
what month in 91 and you get on stage
you remember is July July July or June I
think it's true 18th of July 18th one of
those it's Joe I because it was football
season and the next day I had to do I
got on stage on a Tuesday and a guy
named
bill bill Bauer and another guy that
committed suicide great guy in Denver
asked me to do the Denver Broncos
training camp so my second gig ever was
doing with five minutes in front of a
bunch of rookies from the Broncos and it
didn't go well was that first one a Mike
or a shell the first one was a comedy
works on the Tuesday I went to the
county where some guy on stage
legitimately how'd you get on Comedy
Works it's not an open mic yeah yeah
that's funny I started on a Tuesday too
because I started the at the Hollywood
improv was my first time ever on stage
because they have Mike still every
Tuesday what we do which worked in
nothing I was collecting unemployment I
got fired from my mall job and I was
like 20 and I just stopped working and I
was collecting unemployment I was like
you know what I've always wanted to
start stand-ups this is a perfect time
and I just said I just went up there how
did you feel a drive back to the improv
I felt incredible I felt great I mean
not because I did well but because I
just felt like this huge accomplishment
I was so blinded by my feeling of
accomplishment that I thought I did well
and then the second time I went on stage
I ate a bag of dicks like I actually
realized Oh like I'm not that good you
know I love when comic said when people
say to me I'm only gonna do comedy well
yeah I do first I always think you know
stick get on stage just gone stick don't
sit there and write I love when people
go home right now I'm getting it
together and putting it yeah ever you
lost putting a set together that's what
I did you know I for a year and a half
what your set together I wasn't doing
that yeah I buy every time I'd open a
notebook I'd cry like a little [ __ ]
yeah I would cry the notebook would boo
me boo yeah the beginning and I would
close it like it was a [ __ ] horror
show yeah I always say [ __ ] I'm not
right yeah you just you know you're
mentally scared you you have fear yeah
I'm not I'm not knowing what's coming we
all do this is news for Tommy if you
were a [ __ ] plumber and tomorrow I
promoted you to head plumber and gave
you a loo construction job you wouldn't
sleep that night yeah [ __ ] up
anything else in life you know yeah it's
fear you know it's like when your boss
says da I gotta go to court today for
the [ __ ] [ __ ] you got to run the job
so you gotta lay this pipe in your lady
you know pipette away this [ __ ] by
yourself and I better hang the sheetrock
by yourself you're not gonna pay to hang
these lights but guess what you do it
you do it you might drill a hole that's
bad you might have to come back and
spackle annoy oh you you did it office
mark or three inches off or something
but then you learn for the next what you
learn for the next time and you just get
better and better each time you do it I
don't have a problem with a comic on the
Clubman going hi my name is Johnny
boombots I've been doing comedy for two
years and I think I got 12 minutes and
liked to come down on them say I don't
have a problem with that at all
I have a problem with the guy that cause
of clubbing lies yeah I love me yeah I'd
rather that guy go how many minutes you
got 12 you know what
let's try featuring you the first time I
won't give you a feature money I'll give
you a C+ and just come and try it you
know you you're never gonna know you can
lift 300 pounds do you travel with the
animals so that's it you know this this
is but don't lie on staff lifted it
before you know don't [ __ ] set up a
showcase of Mitzi shore when you're
doing comedy two and a half years and
going there and expect it because that's
why most comics don't do comedy where
they're from
that's why 50% of comics when you go to
them where you from they go Baltimore
you play uh that Clubman walked him on
my boobies don't go know that [ __ ]
guys just come back he hates me you
started that up there doing dinosaur
jokes here fine and a [ __ ] 3pf suit
on that's all he remembers that's why I
tell people we scared away you go
because that's the [ __ ] thing they're
gonna remember and that was this that
you work so hard on that's its getting
ready now get on the stage when you get
on stage and you do it for the first
time that's set you're never gonna say
it again and you work so hard to get it
ready it's a waste of time that's it's
ridiculous to hear that I'm gonna get
that set ready then I'll start it's like
you're not if you're never gonna say
those jokes wait to join jujitsu
I just read that some guys like hey man
look I'll lose 50 Perl before then I
can't you like go in there put that
heavy gear on dude and you sweat that 50
pounds off yeah why you gonna lose the
50 pounds before you do jujitsu anything
that's gonna make a [ __ ] difference
just go in there fat and [ __ ] sweat
it off put an extra t-shirt on and put
an extra key on and [ __ ] go for it
yeah and then if you like it you're
gonna want to lose the [ __ ] problem
it's just fear its natural human fear we
all have to have a little bit of fear to
make this thing work we're all scared of
going into bigger position to all of us
nobody's now I'm going to this people
tell you I got it no you don't when
you're walking into that firm the next
thing you're the [ __ ] lead attorney
on a case you're gonna feel it I don't
give a [ __ ] what you tell me you know
I'm saying it yeah but everybody gets a
chance and either you go through that
wall or you don't go through that wall
what was the first time you featured
probably with you really I think so
where at
I featured one sat at some bar with Greg
Wilson remember when I was really really
young and I only did like we were we
were like late and there and they were
like whoa you guys are like an hour late
and he can only do five and I just did
five but other than that I think the
first time was with you had to be an
improv because that's pretty much where
I feature for you the most in the
beginning there's a lot of improv yeah
was it hard for you to climb out of the
open mic pit you want from being an open
mic to a feature right um oh you haven't
seen a lot I have seed with you I think
a little bit too I am see with you a
little bit before it featured I don't
like I'm seeing but you know everybody
tells you that's what you gotta do you
gotta work we have to feature I didn't I
didn't emcee very often very much I
think I went to feature pretty soon I
think working at a comedy club had a lot
to do with that I learned pretty quick I
got a lot of stage time I had a lot of
material
you got a every night when you worked it
not on the shows I got up every single
day at the open mic and then during the
week I get up every night how can you
describe your journey for people what do
you think so far the 10 years man peaks
and valleys you know - it's so weird how
when you're having a bad month or week
did you feel like it's over so weird I
don't know I I've done a bunch of things
jobs my whole life and there's nothing
else like that when you're having a bad
week or month is you feel like that's it
it's over you're done everything else
you just feel like it's a bad week but
this really feel it feels horrible I
mean but I mean it's a journey you know
you constantly talking to yourself and
going like Oh what do you care for what
that guy is doing and you know it's
wrong to look at other comics and
compare it to yourself but then there's
a little person inside of you going well
how come that [ __ ] guy gets up every
week at the store and I don't you don't
even like you can't help it there's just
so much emotion and and thank God we
have so much podcast now it's it's never
but I don't think it's ever been I don't
want to say easier but to start standing
up an audience has never been more
educated on stand up because the podcast
like you know what you're going into
there wasn't podcast when I started no
one was telling us this like bro there's
gonna be hard times no one was saying
that you just went in that first time I
went up on stage afterward I asked the
guy who was working at The Improv and I
was like so what next like I I remember
saying that Tim so what do I do next and
he's like what do you mean I'm like how
do I get on when I first started juice
was big Comi juice was just blowing up
and they Improv had the posters comedy
just all over the wall and I'll be like
how do I get on that I think I was like
bro today was your first day doing a
breather you know but I think of a lot
of comics today they got podcasts like
you know and and now I know how that's
why I say this is just the beginning I'm
sure I think that I've hit hard times
but I don't think I did anything yet
like it's gonna be just as much as
they're gonna be highs there's gonna be
lows so in the last 10 years that's I
think I'm building thick skin and
getting ready for it you know when you
make the conscious decision to be a
musician when you make the conscious
decision that you want to be an artist
that you wanna do stand-up that you want
to do something that's not in the realm
of everybody else you know man like yeah
most people go to college
they come on they graduate they get a
[ __ ] job and that's that's what they
do and I'm fine with that
you know I'm saying they become doctors
lawyers whatever when you make the
conscious decision to go you know what
man I love music so much I'm gonna teach
the guitar in the daytime or the base or
the drums to you know help my income
when trying to started driving uber yeah
I could teach the guitar you know or
teach the bass and eventually I've got
enough kids in there to cover my nut and
then you do the band you know you do the
band thing but once you make a decision
this one I want people to know there's a
lot of people don't know once you jump
into music art I don't care just not the
daily grind which I'm not saying is bad
either I'm not putting anybody down well
I'm trying to stay this once you get
into that world of arts you know when
you go to prison you come up if you look
deep enough you could get a handicap
sticker yeah you go to prison you come
out and say you're disabled because you
can't get a job that you're a felon and
they'll disobey will you and they'll
give you eight hundred a month and no
I'll find you a [ __ ] and what do you
call it section eight a partner and
they'll do all that for you when we get
on stage are we throw mud at that first
picture or we play the guitar you become
a different you go into a different
category of human being I don't know if
you know this you become a different
category human being so what applies for
different human beings doesn't apply for
you that's why that girl sleeps in her
car even though she's broke and she does
Kylie that's why I Kennison and and and
Carla ball would walk from Westwood to
The Comedy Store and sunset and eat the
fruit for the drinks you know what makes
people do that you know what makes Duff
and for the guys live in the garage and
do music normal people don't do that
yeah if your mother comes over she'll go
Lea get up what are you doing living in
the [ __ ] office with five guys
eating cereal and drinking [ __ ]
whiskey that's what you're living off
because your dream is that you don't
give a [ __ ] I gained 418 pounds I didn't
give a [ __ ] about my health because my
dream was you don't become like normal
people
you're not that normal no more you
become you know how many doctors are
there
I mean lawyers are there I'm gonna stand
up comics are there not too many so
there's something wrong with us
disqualifies this is something wrong so
it pertains to normal human beings
doesn't pertain to us you know people
must look at us and go you did what you
drove to Michigan for $250 who would do
that that's what happens when you become
a guitar player a drummer faith you know
when I become an artist and I stre have
an art [ __ ] exhibit in [ __ ] Las
Vegas we're gonna drive yeah D'Agostino
is prius and you know what one of us
isn't gonna have money for a hotel room
so one of us is sleep when somebody's
[ __ ] for you wouldn't do that for
another under any other conditions
nobody would pick a career where they're
gonna starve for 10 years yeah cuz even
a doctor when he graduates has a paying
job even a lawyer when they graduate law
school they pass the bar they get you
know whatever 80,000 a year to start
depending on what market you with when
you become an artist you become a
different type of human being the
regular rules don't apply to you that's
the hardest part for me like from the
from school to any job I had you always
had what's next
you always kind of know what's next
you're like okay I'm gonna go fungi this
is the promotion I get and then I do
that job or someone will tell me when
I'm going to the next grade or someone
will tell me when I'm getting a blue
belt no no one's gonna tell me and
that's why I get anxiety about like did
I do the right thing with this game cuz
should I have done this should have
taken that geek shine I'm like it's
that's the hard part for me is the
anxiety that I get when no one's telling
you what to do you have to make every
decision for your every decision for
yourself and it's completely different
than
then you're doing and then the Agostino
did and that's the craziest why do you
think I tell you everyone did it call
John Rizzo and Johnny Rock you think I
don't like you no I know but you don't
even call him no more you can't call him
no more because he can't do nothing for
you and I don't want you to feel bad I
had a problem when I was 19 and 20 and
21 I had a big problem the kids I hung
out with all came from money their
families had money so I was always felt
I was always made to feel like a [ __ ]
bumpy somebody always had to pick up my
dinner hmm
you know what they spent in the night I
made in a week yeah do you know what I
am like what they spent on coke and
drinking tonight I know that I had to
catch up and um I tried to keep up with
them and I'd always have to steal and do
this and do that and do it the same
thing as recovery okay
if you hang out with Rogan and Dave
Chappelle and you hear them talk all day
you never feel bad about yourself yeah
yeah I think I feel bad about yourself
if you hit the Agostino and Steve Simone
top all day they're your friends they
love you but you're gonna feel weird
about them they had talked about
managers they talk about agents they
talk about auditions they talk about
showcasing for Montreal they talk about
things that so right away it makes your
psyche want to speed up the process it
makes your psyche make you feel I gotta
get I gotta get there this is why I tell
you every Monday call Johnny Rock call
Rizzo get the [ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out a Leawood get the [ __ ]
out of Hollywood with these kids with
the [ __ ] headshot go to the Mexican
bars learn how to do comedy learn how to
go down there for them and for you to go
I'm here and then think oh there's a
Dodger game on go have a margarita and
wait for the Dodger game to finish you
know this is why I tell you to get a
dose of realism to get a dose of realism
because every open mic here in LA
whether he tells you or not they'll all
tell you the same [ __ ] I don't want to
be rich
I don't want to be then why are you
doing this why are you at Barney's
Beanery you know why are you sleeping in
your [ __ ] you follow me yeah so it
always puts that pressure on you I don't
ever want you to hang out with people
that you can't they can't you get lost
in the what's that movie that came out
lost in the translation
wazzle you get lost in translation then
I try to be scumbags to you you know
it's like when you're 10 and you want to
hang out with your 18 year old brother
he's getting this big sucked he's going
to club yeah can't go you can't go
you're not allowed what do you want me
to tell you I want to go I want to be
like you yeah I know but you can't go
they don't let you that's why I tell you
because you so you're not around
old guys you're around kids your age
that are all looking for the same thing
and you understand each other I don't
understand you right now you don't
understand the Agostino when I talk
these double because we're all at
different levels of comedy nothing wrong
with me D'Agostino being friends in you
and I being friends it's if when you're
around me and [ __ ] Thomas ago all
that how bad are you gonna feel it's
just natural
I learned from being a kid right you
know I hung out with people who their
families had money and Here I am trying
to run with them I'll give them a drink
I buy around the drink I'd be broke $30
I'm broke
Jim they're buying ten rounds of [ __ ]
night plus blow Plus dinner at the diner
afterward so what's the same thing
applies I got stuck in a phase at one
point and I caught myself doing it of
giving a [ __ ] more about what my peers
thought than what the audience thought
it's like are you the audience at the
show yeah like you got into comedy to be
an artist a beep you're a performing
artist to give you my show on stage and
you want to be the best at it at one
point you get caught up with hearing
guys and how well they're doing and then
it becomes about not being an artist
anymore it becomes about I want to be as
good as these guys
and then you start focusing on your
peers too much and then I got that I
went into that little phase where when I
was on stage and Jovi's in the room I
wasn't worried about making the people
laugh I was worried about Joey being in
the room right and then all of a sudden
I caught myself doing it and I'm like I
got to stop doing that stop thinking
about what he thinks and what he thinks
so he thinks I gotta do my performance
on the stage and if they laugh then
whoever else in the backroom is watching
to go [ __ ] themselves
go [ __ ] himself they laugh nothing
bothers me more nothing
you have no idea I must polish when I'm
about to go onstage at Comic Cons you
all onstage come on they'll watch good
my fam whether you not be in the [ __ ]
room cuz now I'm worried about a camera
they don't twenty-eight years still same
thing yeah this certain comics I freeze
up in front of freeze up in front of
another feeling because I know they
critiquing me they're watching me my
every move and they're saying something
to me this is how far back I've been
opening for you I opened for you once an
Ontario improv and you didn't even sit
in the green room because it wasn't sold
out that's how long I've known you when
you weren't sent out the Ontario you
were sitting in the booth in the way
back of the room over there watching the
show and I felt nervous as [ __ ] that you
were sitting there watching the entire
show that's how long I've known you now
you can't sit back there the [ __ ]
cells out here and I mean and he was
just there watching I'm like [ __ ] was he
sitting there watching I used to [ __ ]
with me and then on the drive home I
think I drove with you that at that time
on the drive home you went like you know
you're a very good writer and I was like
aw you know it made me feel good but
then again and I don't want to get
caught up thinking about what other
comics think about me what about what do
you guys I mean obviously you want to do
well but I had an issue or so you were
saying when you go through bad periods
the first four to five months of this
year I wasn't happy with what I was
doing and I felt the issue for me was as
I started to get some cool shows like I
started to do some shows and so I was
constantly working on the stuff that I
knew worked and for whatever reason I
felt like everything I was writing
didn't work and I was always trying to
do very like I was always trying to do
too well I
think onstage ma I didn't want to take a
chance well I got bad news for you
that's gonna come and go you know like
right now you're gonna think I'm doing
good and you'll go back and look at last
week's video and you'll be like I can't
believe that was me I'm better now but
next year you're gonna look at you right
now
I think that you're [ __ ] now oh yeah no
I'm but it's it was hard for me to make
that transition to be like I can I have
to right you got stuck you know it's
okay everybody just it's hot when dough
how long did it take you guys to get
over that I want to do amazing every set
I mean you always want to do amazing
every set ly nobody's paying to go see
you I know think about people paying to
go see you mm-hmm
that's even more anxiety about when
somebody goes to see you they haven't
get a babysitter there are four tickets
they went to dinner and Mark I'm gonna
see dude I'm just surprised that you can
remember a full hour of material not you
in general just people can remember a
full hour that's where you get onstage
in it for Jesus think I'm not I didn't
say that to put you down no no I didn't
see you and everybody wants to do good
listen whether you play baseball the
harmonica the flute you suck dick you
take it in the ass you want you're good
at what you do you always want to do
good at what you do but you're trapped
remember it's a process and you're
learning and that's what people forget
they get caught up somewhere for a short
period of time don't get happened to me
it happens to everybody
nobody [ __ ] gets nobody falls out of
this you get caught up in this [ __ ] and
you forget the ended listen about three
weeks ago I got off the plane from New
York feeling good about myself about
being in the movie then I went on
Facebook and somebody found a funny is
funny said of me did you see it
what I have a red shirt what doesn't
even know what that is funny it's funny
it was funny was a show they taped at
The Improv in 98 I watched three minutes
of that set and I wanted a head but
[ __ ] computer screen it was an hour
guys is the scary thing this is that I'm
not ashamed to say that I was already in
LA
and that was [ __ ] job awful job offer
I already passed this door pass at the
store doing spots at the store you know
[ __ ] fight banging it out people
burying me bombing and I watched that
daven I felt bad for myself like I was
like if I would watch that for reals
like when it came out I would probably
quit like that ad on TV I'm Telemundo or
something I don't know where the [ __ ] it
is and I'm sure people do socks up that
[ __ ] hey listen man that's what this is
all about it's about growing you know
you look it it's a couple months ago I'd
listen to I got on all the CDs I taped
on my ipod on the plane I put one of
them on I almost had a [ __ ] heart
attack if I could have jumped out of the
plane without a parachute I you know
that's natural we all want to do better
you know but you also have to see where
you're at you also have to see with your
materials that and you also have to know
that even Dave Chappelle bombs even Dave
Chappelle bombs
he doesn't bomb as much as we do because
people pay $80 to see him and they're
not gonna tell people that he ate a bag
of dog haha do you follow me Dave
Chappelle could go into a stage right
now charge you guys 100 bucks a ticket
and do a whole hour of workout material
and make you laugh ten times you're not
gonna tell your friends he sucked yeah
cuz then you look like you got me you
look like you got beat so always
remember that that we could you know
everybody bombs everybody bomb you know
I still want being at the store and
Chris Rock getting a standing ovation on
the way up he's not gonna bomb right
he's not gonna bomb if he says boo
they're gonna laugh just out of impulse
you know you mind this train that's why
I always tell me you said so I'm
interesting to me that then you having a
hard time with bar shows big difference
you know I said that the other day about
dice tonight somebody wrote some stupid
[ __ ] on Facebook that they didn't like
the podcast he was on and he was douchey
and I'm like listen bro I don't put
nobody on that I don't love
and I judge them by what's in their
heart dice when it comes to stand-up
comedy
he's like I had started 40 years he's
like Einstein he will tell you things
that your head will [ __ ] blow up he
will tell you the psychology you know
authors good at that Ralphie man
Ralphie man was very good the psychology
of the audience something that you don't
need to think of for 10 years but the
psychology of the audience is basically
when you go to a comedy club you
predetermined to laugh Chris D'Elia yeah
I'll go on to a comedy club when you go
to a bar that do drugs on a Tuesday and
my joke Diaz is onstage doing push-ups
totally different set of mine yeah
totally different you're going into
battle ground instead of so the psyche
of the person going to watch comedy is
also very different he's going to a
[ __ ] he's gonna watch a Dodger game
at the local pub and he gets there and
he his chili chatter from the back
there's 20 people in the back and
there's these [ __ ] jerk-off comedians
in the back but three weeks you just
don't look back there's no [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah and one day son actually
go back there cuz maybe Ali Wong is back
there he why he saw Ali Wong I think you
know I'm saying so you have to win
people over so the psyche of the person
wanna watch comedy when you go into
these places to do comedy I don't want
you to think about it as a star as a
young comic and I'm talking about young
comic up to 7 years 10 year you have to
think about the psyche kill you on it
just think about going up there getting
your footing on the making people laugh
as best that you can
that's it making people laugh as best as
you can die said it best the other way
stop thinking stop thinking about it
there's not a thing about thinking you
always get you in trouble especially as
a man think about when you go home at
night you're tied you [ __ ] doublet
wrench you killed your wife you work 10
hours you [ __ ] 20 women you're tired you
go home I don't think you think of
something and now you're wide awake yeah
only a thought could get keep you wide
awake that and [ __ ] sugar or met
thinking is the worst thing in the
[ __ ] world for you what are you
thinking about
well you know what is the thing about
dick everything go on man do 15 minutes
shut your mouth just be funny don't
think about tomorrow what do you have to
worry about tomorrow or what they're
gonna think about every time and I'm
telling you from experience and every
time I thought it gets you in trouble
what are you thinking about all you need
is tell us what you don't tell it I'm
working on this new bit about dogs
getting hit by cars ah you lost just go
down and be organic just go down and do
the [ __ ] job you know I got it one
thing I got a hand about you D'Agostino
10 years you just put your head down you
taking [ __ ] from all angles yeah you
know you hear there and it doesn't
matter one thing that really got to me
last year was a [ __ ] jerk-off with
the Comedy Store if you go into the
comics drawer the mitzi sure hates you
and throws you out do you think you're
done with Tommy
no he's just not gonna work the store
you could still end up being louis c.k a
Dave Chappelle yeah if the Improv throws
you out you could still be louis c.k
Dave Chappelle if the Laugh Factory told
you if the funny bone throws you out and
banned you from the funny bone chain you
could still be delicious Louise c-care
Dave Chappelle and if the improv straw
yeah you could still there's no excuses
if you really want if you really want it
there's no excuse you know look at Louie
CK got fired from every Network he was a
head business with it's a it has even
stopped him but he found the way to
still get on stage and work out when
nobody wants Idol when it comes to
comics I'll tell you whose door will
work and who's not
I'll tell you cuz I've been there I know
what it is to do the work I know what it
is to do the work and then there's a
difference between doing the work and
working smarter so my first three years
I did the work once I saw Leguizamo I
went back to Colorado I started working
smart and that's when you start
improving and leave some balance that's
where the improvement comes all every 90
days you're like oh wow I got new five
minutes I you know I [ __ ] did this I
tried a new joke in the middle of my set
opened up with my closer don't force
yourself to do that open up with your
closer and take whatever is coming to
you like a man I've done that for years
I love dribble runs open up with your
closure and take what's coming to you
take the beat and take the third it's
like sitting down and somebody smacking
you with a glove then you smack you with
the hand then just backhand you're like
the French yeah that's it that's it
those are our open up with your closer
and take a chance and see we end up
those are my favorite [ __ ] spots
daren't that's where you that's what I
miss about Denver term as soon as face
right now just about that no go with
take disgusting you're breathing it
already it's already going into your
lungs what's the difference yeah it's
probably why I got asthma yeah you got
that DNA yeah yeah bronchitis nice got
asthma the bunker my mother said I got
nothing you got that you got lungs made
for 120 and you're walking around at 280
and your lungs like little peanuts and
you can't breathe the same problem I got
I'm a fat [ __ ] my lungs are made for
somebody 190 and I'm 300 pounds
sure you gotta breathe heavy your lungs
are the size of your little head I think
every time you walk up the stairs you
take this [ __ ] what happens to your
lungs no that's why I heard of it that's
why I asked you to stretch out your lung
to smoke more reefer no wine the offer
and now you're like a half a [ __ ] yeah
yeah
two weeks ago was bronchitis nobody was
getting bronchitis every mind these days
now was it
I only get it once a year no you did ya
ever got before I start not a high no
you never got you tip-top Magoo you a
baller how la smog Li balls help yeah
[ __ ] dad what little things would you
say that you picked up from sitting in
the back at the improv and watching
headliners that you remember that you
specifically went like okay that's the
difference that I had buddies to him
what did you learn
confidence I learned not that I use it
but I learned how they structure their
jokes I always wanted to do callbacks
and that's what I got I had worked on
callbacks a lot in law you know and I
just learned how to be a headliner you
know a headliner is 45 minutes it's
three 15-minute pieces there's a
beginning a middle and then they just
like a book you know I was going up then
pulling the Rodney for 45 minutes okay
which I still kind of do which is open
line
open close no nothing Oakland clothes
all dirty there wasn't no beginning a
middle or an ending everything has a
beginning a middle and mm-hmm and that's
what I got out of it and that was that
there 15 year March and don't tell me
what 20-something years so this had to
be 2009-2010 18 year mark right before I
met you was one I when I met you yeah I
had just finished that World Tour
headliners and I was still on the fence
about quitting I was still very much on
the fence about getting a day job doing
little spots here and there and just
hopefully off a rope and I was very
content I was doing San Jose you know
everybody was taking care of me while I
was taking care of me I had my room in
Brea yeah I remember that I was for a Oh
every month I had the dirty showing Brea
so I had things going on I just didn't
know you know and that's what I'm saying
that when you pick this life you never
know what's gonna come from day to day
so stop guessing and stop trying to
guess stop guessing and stop trying to
guess this is everyday something
different just like I I watch you and
I'm very proud I'm looking in the eye
and Tonya's because you did the work
you know you did the work I watched you
do the work regardless of what people
are doing just do a little piece and you
got your day job you know I'm saying to
keep you together but now that you're
gonna start the headline now in two or
three is that day job has to go away
yeah how you have it's like the Flying
Wallendas you gotta pull the net away
you can have a net from Steve someone I
were talking about how many guys we saw
that didn't make it in this town because
they kept that [ __ ] day jobs like the
Percy name three people would have had
careers today if they were to call it
dead day jobs
what's a career a career is making six
figures a year maybe shooting TV show
maybe a stand-up thing for Comedy
Central that's a career where I come
from yeah doing what you love getting
six figures and that's a career you know
I am but they never quit their day job
you're telling your mind that you don't
have enough confidence and what you're
doing up there
I mean even Rodney Rodney did it and
they had to go back to work for a few
years if you know Rodney story but those
two years he kept writing and he stacked
those [ __ ] notebooks up with work so
when he came back he had 22 hours of
material so every time he had a special
or some spot on TV showed up with an
extra six minutes people thought he was
a genius
no he just never stopped right just
because he didn't perform he kept
writing he kept writing he kept writing
he kept writing he kept writing he kept
writing he kept putting all those
one-liners boy just chunking them away
in a notebook so he had that day job
yeah they jump selling aluminum siding
he had a day job he went back to a day
job and then he [ __ ] quit that read
the Wikipedia reading web page right
it's really interesting okay I want you
to you have to give yourself that
conference you tell if you do you keep
your day job you telling me you don't
have the confidence in your stand-up to
take it to that level
you know like I said I didn't get in
this to be Kevin Hart or louis c.k but
I'm pretty happy now that we ended up
where we did yeah I didn't get in this
to be on TV I didn't think I could book
a headshot when I got it
honest to god guys honest to god I swear
the mercy that I never thought I'd be an
extra I thought I'd be an extra so this
is just one of these [ __ ] you know
and like I said in the beginning of life
is art same thing life is art you're
gonna have struggles people gonna come
and go you know when you have a day job
right this three weeks you don't sound
on insurance you quit
oh you're going through a cold spell
well maybe you're not reading the pitch
right maybe you're going off the pitch
and you're not ask them to buy maybe
you're talking too much it's gonna
focusing on the clothes everything has
an answer you know what I told I think
I've had discussions to boëthius and
I've been on a bombing streak you know
this times I go on a bombing street and
what do you do you quit no I like when
you're a baseball player and you you go
oh for 15 they don't bite you they know
that eventually you're gonna get your
eye back yeah it's so weird that's a
crazy one of me is that baseball you're
like an all-star if you fail seven out
of ten times 300 is the best you can
hope for and in hitting if I if I bombed
seven out of ten times I don't know if
I'd be a comedy like yeah you would
really because maybe those reach times
you got standing ovations and somebody
died in the audience okay you know I'm
sayin yeah man last time I went to Lisa
at show I got a diabetic seizure I went
to see him he bound yeah but last time I
went to see him he killed the
[ __ ] don't you enjoy what you're
doing regardless if you like would you
just quit if you had seven bombs in a
row don't you like being a comic like
you didn't do it to be the best in the
world you did it because you enjoy it
like I enjoy I enjoy going onstage
trying something I don't know what's
gonna happen
and seeing why it didn't work and then
fixing it up put it absolutely I enjoy
it I enjoy the fail it's a part of it
it's like it's fun
that's the job to be I'm still at a
place now where I used to get upset with
myself if I bombed at an open mic which
isn't even really a thing but I don't
know if I'd quit if I bomb seven times
in a row but it it takes it out of me
when I get upset with myself and then
also and who knows maybe it's just a
further along you make more concessions
I don't know if I'd be living in a car
like I don't know if if I loved standing
up enough like that that when I see
people doing I'm like that's a different
level of of commitment that I'd be like
okay well it's time to get a job and
made do it a little bit at night mm-hm
like that that's a different level that
to be honest I don't know if I have
we'll find out you know that this is
what this is this is I I had nothing
else well I got the comedy so I had
nothing else to love hmm I had nothing
else to love I tried to love a thousand
things and don't nobody love me back
you never saying nobody love me back and
I'm not saying that people love me I do
come it was still [ __ ] him yeah but
you don't see my pictures of improv you
don't see nothing I'm not even
considered a [ __ ] stand up I really
don't give a [ __ ] I still don't know
bomb in two weeks on a row on a triple
run and getting bad reports every night
like you know you get into a club and
them going you know there's a Mormon
audience they don't want to hear cursor
I didn't know how I just my set in those
days I was gonna stand up four or five
years the material I had I had what are
you telling me I can't do my material I
borrow I never thought of quit because I
knew that I had to go through this I
knew that I had to go through this you
know when you walk into a boxing gym
you're not gonna be the best boxer in
that place the first [ __ ] here the
first year you gonna get beat up every
[ __ ] time you go to spar once a we
get beat up but after the first year you
know start throwing a couple jabs and
connecting but at the two years your
combos would be
acting young saying but after three
years one of the guys in the gym is
[ __ ] doing an amateur fight and you
get there and they scratch him because
he's overweight but you made weight so
you get in there without even prepare
him and you win now what now your life
changes now I won well you know I'm
saying this is what the beauty is about
life life is art all right mimics live
life lumix art you know even if you work
at a bank with you an investment bank or
whatever you've got ups and downs bro
life ain't [ __ ] easy
you know think of the person today that
has two kids think of a [ __ ] family
that has two kids and both parents after
work and they still put [ __ ] on that
credit card you know every time I go to
a Dodger game the first thing I think
about is how lucky am i I'd like to take
my wife my uncle my daughter to a
baseball game this family is a four they
can't afford to [ __ ] them and they both
work hard anything those people feel
both parents work and they can't afford
a [ __ ] Dodger game because if they
got a flat tire during the week that
goes their [ __ ] month that goes down
month of tires what $70 $30.00 dollars
you know I'm saying that's how hard they
work so life is art you're gonna have a
hard time with everything you [ __ ] do
whether it's making posters whether it's
whatever pick what you love it's all
gonna suck yeah so you might as well
pick what your love if I'm gonna hate it
work listen let's get it on you know I
hate going to work hate it hate it I'll
take the job oh yeah I'll take I'll pick
up for three weeks another Thursday when
that person says no I don't want to buy
him they hang up on you and you get like
god damn it I've only made thought maybe
I was this week what the [ __ ] I could
make 20,000 one night selling coke I
would quit I never gave me the chance
this is the only thing I didn't quit
yeah was it hard for you to start asking
for money for standing up or that wasn't
an issue when I got it to stand up day I
knew there was no money right now I
understand that I asked questions so
everybody that told me I put it in my
mind that the first ten years I'm the
megalodon
I had
already set but after 10 years I'm not
making any money I don't want to make no
money
I don't want to think about it I don't
want to think about it I don't want
because money is ruins you with commie
money is what ruins commie I want you to
fall in love with comedy before you
start [ __ ] with the money aspect of
it because if you really love comedy the
money won't mean none to you you're just
happy that you're doing what they pay me
120 and all the shushei kitty open bar
hell yeah the hotel room I'm going right
I'm going and if you don't do it
somebody else will and you lose the
stage time yeah you know there was a
lady in Seattle Laura Crocker god rest
her soul she's dead [ __ ] it but she was
a book of when I was up there she
managed Josh whoa she didn't like me she
didn't like me she booked all these
rooms and she didn't like me but I
didn't like her either so I would call
her up every Wednesday no can I do a
showcase she had like 22 rooms I would
call every week and say can I do a
showcase there and there was nothing she
could say that man she'd go yeah you
could do it I wasn't getting paid I was
better than all free comics that she had
paid huh
I was better than the headline of the
feature and the emcee she paid I didn't
let it bother me I looked at as a spot I
looked at that as a spot I don't have to
go to [ __ ] on the fourth wall and pay
them five hours it's a spot I didn't
care that she didn't pay me I didn't
give a Frenchman's [ __ ]
guess what well I got into the [ __ ]
store as a regular that night in my mind
I thanked her for being a [ __ ] to me and
to making me fight that hard to do those
guest spots every week do you know the
same yeah so if you get into comedy this
is why so many people get into
podcasting and quit and so many people
get into comedy and quit because they
think this is abundance of money listen
guys if you're getting into a podcast
today to make money you got a better
chance of over hmm got a better chance
over it you do a podcast because you
want to do it from your heart you enjoy
getting your message out there
the same thing would stand up when you
get into stand-up I've seen all I've
seen all the guys that were concerned
with money all of them so wait a second
you do the Comi stormy night for $15
your ass at I did the home brewery last
week for 50 bucks great yeah do it for
50 bucks what do you want from me you
made 35 more than me paid you that one
gig was every three months good for you
good thing when you're in town we don't
see you I didn't worry about money and I
had child support at a cocaine problem I
rent out a thousand things I didn't
worry about money the money will come if
God wants me to have the money on the
29th of the month I'm gonna call saying
go to the ha pick up 500 you're opening
up for my zebrano this weekend and if
you put the work in if you put the work
into whatever career you're in love with
I guarantee
right now with your situation okay in
about a year or two you'll have to quit
to start at like if you go out every
night right every day and believe in
what you're doing I guarantee you as a
man that you will make in not every
month I will make that promise to
anybody who listens to that podcast if
you go into something blind that you
really love and you really put the work
into it every day every day 9:00 to
10:00 at night I guarantee you'll make
your nut whether it's 1,500 a month or
4,000 won you know I know cuz I've been
there and that's when I was doing well
that's before I was doing you understand
me that's what I really have problems
that's when I was snorting 300 a week I
mean my drug bill a month used to be
2,000 a month damn and I was making $15
spots so don't come to me with none of
your [ __ ] stories but I knew that
every month I did the work every month I
did the work and every month I going
[ __ ] what am I gonna tell Terry it's the
20th and rent doesn't even look like
it's coming in my future and on the 25th
I get a call from Shoob
or somebody going hey and you know I you
hang up the phone in UI I get it that
but if you quit your day job and you put
a hundred percent in I'm not talking
about going to a coffee shop in the
daytime and hanging when you [ __ ]
loser buddies head talking about you
know well rock doesn't like special
wasn't he good it was overrated you're
not going nowhere and you might as well
hang you yeah you might as well pull up
Brody Stevens you're not going nowhere
whatever you like the way I was working
in Seattle like me Josh and then [ __ ]
the Brody the way we're working in
Seattle we're making a living I was
paying rent every month I was making a
hundred dollars a set drama were you
talking about 50 and I was getting $25
Richards on Friday the host a Navy base
but at the end of the month if you put
the work in you will make your nothing
then so because I was paying child
support went snorting sucking [ __ ]
drinking you know and there's some
months of the better than others yeah
you're gonna have one month out of 12
that you haven't you'll have to borrow
100 or that's you know I went to
Columbus this weekend and I went to
Atlanta last two weeks in a row I lost
my luggage really yeah Atlanta lost a
big suitcase this week I lost the little
suitcase for my boxing gloves but a Muay
Thai do I look upset to you not upset
you know why I feel like 30 times a year
yeah and they lost it once twice this is
what happens it's so law percentages
yeah it's the law of percentages just
works in flying this works in comedy and
this works in life that's why when
people come up to me now I have an old
comedy for eight years
should I quit my job it's up to you jump
do you know that if you quit your day
job you're working eight hours a day
right yeah you have to work ten doing
common yeah that's the phones that's
working the phones emails getting in
your car going down and talking to this
guy see if you get up next week for his
show I mean thing you know it's telling
him he goes I call that guy he never hit
me back get down there drive down it
show the guy you want to do the wrong
that's it that's like it hardly never
happens over the phone man no no you
gotta go down there it sounds crazy but
like 90% of the gigs I get is because he
was like dude gotta go Simon you're like
I was just thinking about you gotta go I
decided of mind gotta get out of the
house and then you ask yourself how come
that guy has spots and I did it because
they wouldn't there no nobody [ __ ]
time since I've been in this town I've
said to myself I'm taking the head off
and the store like when I first got here
I would think like whatever night NYPD
Blue is on should the girl like David
okay [ __ ] so I wanted to take a night
off because I was so condensed with
comedy
you know how many times I would say like
I'm taking the night off and that's six
o'clock I go night off yeah [ __ ] you and
I go down there
all the nights that was the biggest
night I get like an audition somebody
would give me a gig and on the drive
home on mic that's why I realized yeah I
did as a comic they come like once 90 I
started comedy in 91 and yeah so the
first two or three years I [ __ ] around
for the first two years I [ __ ] around
I didn't know what I was doing I was
snoring and doing this but in 93 there
was no more TV in my house TV
disappeared TV disappeared gave it away
brand new Sony Trinitron because if
you're a real comic you're not gonna
watch TV
you're not gonna binge watch TV you know
watch Game of Thrones when you're a real
calm you don't want dick those first 10
years those first 12 years you know
nothing I don't do nothing less my first
12 years nothing I didn't know anything
baseball football I didn't know I didn't
know about sports I lost touch with
everything all I thought about
especially when I got here when I got
here I really turned it on because I
knew this was the major leagues to st.
the minor leagues the st. triple-a ball
the st. double-a ball to say in st. wait
ball this is hard ball this is real
[ __ ] ball in it you gotta turn it up
I didn't know nothing about staying and
Stan
staying in my wife left October at 91 -
from the night my life my wife left till
2004 I never stayed it I'm not saying I
drank every night I'm not saying that I
partied every night I'm telling you I
did not stay in every night because even
if I would didn't have a spot I want to
see the headline mm-hmm what are the
nights I even if I didn't have a spot
like we were talking about being over
Mike or how Sunday through Thursday yeah
you have a lot of action then on the
weekends you have nothing
and sadly Friday I'd deliver pizzas yes
you're not gonna if you're not gonna go
do calmly you might don't make money
yeah go deliver pizza go go do something
and then sadly I would pay and go see a
headliner at the Comedy Works I can go
see whoever was hot Bobby Collins the
kids from Boston Boston Commons all
those guys I used to go see him at the
Cotton hey yeah yeah Wow Jackie Flynn
you know all those Daleks Steve McGrew
just I can't remember how many [ __ ]
car the guy you know you you must be a
redneck I paid to see Seinfeld in
concert in the theater in Bandra did you
really yeah can't picture you doing that
yeah yeah no I did I forgot to call me I
knew that you don't know watch what
these guys are doing you got to go watch
you gotta go [ __ ] pay attention when
you're a double a baseball player you go
watch the Dodgers on your days off you
wanna go see well [ __ ]
what's-his-name is doing how much was
that Seinfeld take it you remember a
girl waterfall not a date I told the
girl I really wanted to go and I got her
a job and she got a first check and she
to repay my okay she paid for the ticket
I had a really good time and Seinfeld
was clean and you know whatever the [ __ ]
it was did you like him yeah I always
liked science up I always liked science
ah but he had a joke about how does a
hair crawl up the wall in the shower
that's my favorite joke of his uh you
would take a shower when there's a hair
right across the way yeah how does it
climb up the wall I was [ __ ] dying I
love
D'Agostino I want to tell you I'm really
proud thank you I'll keep doing what
you're doing obviously it's working
what's the name of your podcast on
homeschooled like a [ __ ] and you
have a website and every day
yeah homeschooled pod dot-com or also
Agostino comedian com same thing listen
guys I know a lot of yous came out to
support me in Minneapolis its fourth of
July weekend you don't watch fireworks
on Thursday night Friday Saturday and
Sunday Friday and Sunday for any signs
in all of America if you're not doing it
there's a personal [ __ ] friend of mine
I love him to death he's a hard worker
he's like my little brother he covered
my ass years ago when I was doing spots
at the store I'm very proud of it thank
you happy that you had lining in the I
wish is the beginning of great things
for you man I appreciate it thank you
very much for being on the other date
you got right now that's it just those
let's just focus on those right now
yeah I'm just focusing on the
[ __ ] rec room this Friday night
in Huntington Beach Friday first show
sold out second show it's myself and
cake Quigley and my man little gay I
love that little gay guy oh he's awesome
I haven't seen him I haven't seen in a
while I haven't seen him in a while he's
gonna host for me and then uh July 10th
through the 12th I'm at the
[ __ ] Charlotte comedy zone with
my main man had a [ __ ] Louisville
Brad Lanny
that's my dog Louis I love him to death
and that's it that's that it's fourth of
July week but we want to give you a
little something to start off your
[ __ ] Monday morning with real quick I
want to read a little message from our
sponsors and I'll let you go on and get
your [ __ ] fireworks I'm very upset
they confiscated $50,000 worth of
fireworks and a ship today in southern
that will come to my way I was in the
blower please building I was in the buy
a quarter stick of dynamite but they
[ __ ] it up and that's it and that's
that but number one listen
hiring is hard you know hiring is a is a
challenge it's hard to find qualified
candidates it takes a long time too many
applicants blah blah blah blah blah blah
listen zipper crew
makes it easier alright but there's one
place where you could go multiple
jobsite stacks of resumes confusing
review process
but today hiring can be easy and only
you have to go to one place to get it
done and that's zip recruiter comm slash
Church okay zip recruiter cinch your job
over a hundred of the web's leading job
boards but they don't stop there as
applicants come in the zip recruiter
analyzes each one excuse me in
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip recruit is
so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through that site
are you ready for this within one day
one day no more stacks of paperwork no
more phone ringing off the hook
no more twenty hours to find the right
guy within 24 hours
zip recruiter will find the perfect
applicant for you and right now the
church family can try zip recruiter for
free gratis near-dead birthday right now
go to zip lacunae comm slash Church CH
you are CH that zipper cool calm slash
Church zip recruiter the smallest way to
hire the church is also brought to you
by manscaped I don't know how many
[ __ ] times I'm gonna leave town like
an itchy balls when I go to reach down I
got like split ends on my deck the split
ends up my hair like I'm supposed to
condition my ball hair and I feel bad
cuz I always forget the condition your
ball hair and the hair above your dick
so it gets split ends and gets dry [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
use manscape trim that [ __ ] off you want
your dick to look like a [ __ ] marine
you understand me with man shade with
manscaped you will not cut your dick off
[ __ ] oh the suffering ends today no
anxiety no nothing
they got precision tools for the Family
Jewels manscaped has redesigned the
electric razor their invention is called
the lawn mower a handheld razor with
skin-safe technology so it won't Nick or
snag your [ __ ] nut sack
or your loved Pole cuz you gotta go easy
on what the Lord
gave you this bad boy will leave your
smooth clean and guess what it's pain
free plus manscaped is rechargeable easy
to hold so you get it on to all the
nooks and crannies manscape will get
your [ __ ] bag of debt looking like a
[ __ ] model you're I'm saying you
could call me a little ball head to the
side to the side and look tremendous and
I'm gonna let you in on a little secret
if you trim the hedges the tree will
look a lot taller so what the [ __ ] are
you waiting for go to manscape calm
right now and get everything you need to
make your dick and your balls shine and
keep your dick looking pretty [ __ ]
good too if this is the first time
you're gonna go to manscape do me a
favor
consider getting the perfect package it
comes with a lawnmower and a safety
razor plus the crop preserver especially
formulated deodorant so your balls don't
stink I got it on right now if I take a
whiff it smells like tiramisu and the
Reviver a Sprint's that tones your nuts
ex and refreshes your dick and your love
pole to keep you nice and [ __ ] cool
in these summer months with the humidity
and whatnot so do me a favor again the
church family gets 20% off your first
order when you use promo code church at
manscape calm listen don't let another
summer go by and you not get your dick
sucked cuz it smells like a [ __ ]
jungle down there if you want to get
your dick sucked you want to pull that
bean out like louis c.k and you want it
to look good maybe of louis c.k had
manscaped he wouldn't be in all the
trouble he's in right now you understand
me
so go right now at a manscape calm and
if you're the perfect package they'll
throw in a free travel bag when you use
promo code Church that's manscaped that
time use promo code Church for 20% off
your first order keep your balls clean
your dick nice and smooth then you won't
have louis c.k fight problems you know
same and that's it and that's that don't
forget the rec room Friday
10 o'clock show and then Charlotte the
comedy zone July 10th to the 12th I love
your [ __ ] we'll see you
Wednesday morning tip top Magoo ready to
[ __ ] go kick this [ __ ] muley